there are some glimmers of hope in the
country
one bit was actually during the super
bowl there was an ad
during the super bowl these are usually
extremely woke that was maybe the most
pro-life tv commercial i've ever seen
you have this swimmer and she
is missing part of her legs
very well shot mrs long yes
we've found a baby girl for your
adoption but there are some things you
need to know
she's in siberia and she was born with a
rare condition
her legs will need to be amputated
i know this is difficult to hear her
life
it won't be easy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mrs long it might not be easy but
it'll be amazing
i can't wait to meet her
we believe there is hope and strength in
all of us
toyota proud partner of team usa
it's a beautiful advertisement it's
really great this girl you know was
going to be adopted born in siberia
she's got this condition
they say well yeah we're still going to
take her we don't care that she has a
disability
and she becomes this paralympic athlete
that's wonderful now
they couldn't have made it about you
know a woman who's contemplating
abortion and
maybe you know the kid in in utero is
diagnosed with some condition well
is he's going to have a tough condition
oh well i'm going to have the baby
anyway i'm not going to get you they
couldn't get away with that
but it's exactly the same issue am i
going to keep the kid or am i going to
give the kid away either to siberia or
to death
and the ad was saying no choose life
that's good
even even though there is suffering in
the world
it's okay it's better to live this world
involves
suffering i was reminded of this on my
flight to dc
because basically the only time that i
ever wear the mask these days is when
i'm on an airplane because you they
won't let you on the airplane
if you don't wear the mask if you refuse
to wear the mask while you're on the
airplane they will arrest you i mean
it's not
then they'll put you on the no-fly list
and you just can't travel anymore so
it's the only time where i've made a
prudential judgment i think it's better
to put the mask on and go
talk about how fauci is a jerk and no
one should listen to him you know go
talk about him on various shows and
things like that
then to not not travel at all i was very
uh
sort of crestfallen at this sad state of
affairs for the country
uh the way we're all locked down like
lemmings wearing these stupid
muzzles on our faces these filthy pieces
of cloth
flying in to cover this fake impeachment
trial which is dominating the national
attention
all sorts of glib nonsense vile
racial politics creeping up all over the
place
republicans without a spine and i was
joking though i had
boethius in my bag this writer who wrote
the the consolation of philosophy
he wrote it while he was in prison about
to be executed by
the gothic emperor theodoric and
he wrote the consolation of philosophy
about how you know look fortunes go up
fortunes fall and there's a lot of
suffering in this world
and uh compared to what boethius was
facing probably we've got it pretty
pretty good
and but by pursuing truth
you can rise above that you can realize
yeah this is a broken fallen world
boethius a lot of people don't know was
a christian he's actually venerated as
a saint in the catholic church you can
rise above that sort of thing
and it just doesn't uh you shouldn't let
that
get you down i think we're in that kind
of place right now in our country
things just look terrible they just look
really bleak and there are very few
glimmers of hope
but hope springs eternal in the human
breast and i'll probably be more hopeful
when i get out of washington d.c
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you